this is a production of Cornell
University
okay yeah so I'm here today to talk
about some recent work I've been working
on in epistasis and alle polyploid okay
so in your typical hybrid production at
some point you have some alleles so yeah
some alleles that are floating around in
an open pollinated population and then
at some point either intentionally or
unintentionally they get separated from
one another and you end up with
different heterotic groups and then when
those heterotic groups are brought back
together you end up with a hybrid and
you've established a hetero zygosity and
essentially all loci in the genome right
okay so now you've got these allelic
interactions which we think are what is
important is part of what is important
for hybrid vigor in these progeny and so
uh excuse me and so I like to think of a
low polyploid as hybrids and the reason
why is because you start off with a
common ancestor that has some set of
alleles okay and then through through
gene mutation and evolution this thing
specie eights into two species a and B
and then that are still more or less
related to each other but hybridization
between them becomes relatively rare and
wet but when it does happen you bring
both of these genomes together into the
same organism and you have established
essentially hetero zygosity at all the
low side okay so based on this of maybe
we have some homeo allelic interaction
okay and these may be what's important
for why we is so while why a lot of our
crop species including we are so widely
adapted okay so a brief reminder of
epistasis epistasis is the interaction
between two low five and these lows I
can have you know I'm showing two low
side B and C here I'm showing for the
inbred case because a lot of alle
polyploid are instantly sexually
isolated they usually cannot continue to
out cross
after that hybridization event so they
have to self in order to in order to
continue on but what's cool about that
is they end up fixing all of these
allelic interactions right so you
maintain a little of diversity across
your sub genomes while preserving your
your genotype by selfing okay and so you
can have two low side B and C perhaps
these are homeo allelic right so one is
on the a genome one on the B genome and
there's various models we could have for
how these genes might have an
interaction so a will be the effect on
the phenotype okay and you have the the
classic multiplicative interaction which
you see often you may also have like a
duplicate factor interaction which is
which is analogous to two genes that
have essentially the same function and
so if you have a functional copy of one
or the other you get the effect in
otherwise you don't and similarly we
have complementarity which is which is
like two genes in a pathway you need to
functional alleles in order to get the
result but you'll notice that in in
breads and this isn't true for hybrids
or I'm sorry heterozygous populations
you'll notice that the complementary is
essentially just a mathematical inverse
of the duplicate factor okay so I'm not
going to talk about the complimentary
anymore but I will revisit the duplicate
factor and so I would like to propose
another way to look at this epistatic
problem that is related to sub function
ization okay so the idea is there is
some haplotype a in the in the ancestor
okay and then through time and mutation
you get a change in this in this allele
a or you can allow these alleles to
diverge in their function they don't
have to but you can allow them to okay
and then when you bring them back in to
the same organism like in an olive
polyploid you essentially give to some
of their effects times some divergence
from their initial value okay so the
idea here is you'll notice that when D
equals one
they have diverged such that they have
completely new function and so they no
longer perform the same function within
the organ of
and when D equals 0.5 and these are
equal they essentially have they have
not diverged in their function okay and
everything in between and past right so
so my my sub functionalization epistatic
model actually covers sub
functionalisation which is when D is in
between zero point or a half and one but
we it allows for a completely additive
model as well as for something that's
like over dominance when D is greater
than one there's something about having
the sum you know having two things is
greater than the sum of its parts
which you could come up with all kinds
of fun biological reasons for and then
of course when D equals zero this ends
up being the inverse of the
multiplicative which is kind of
complicated and I'm not going to go into
it okay
so from an ordinary least-squares
perspective you can think of this
problem as a lineage of effect for the B
allele and additive effect for the C
allele and then an interaction okay and
what's cool is in in inbreds if they're
truly inbred you can code all of the
markers as 0 or 1 okay so you either
have the B allele or you don't have the
B allele and then the interaction is
just the product of those and so here
I've got like so this I'm showing like
marker scores but then you've also got
this is just like a design matrix right
and then this would be the additive
effect of a of B C and then the
interaction effect as beta and what's
nice about this is because you only have
zeros and ones this nasty matrix algebra
looking thing here really simplifies
into a much more simple equation that is
just a function of allele frequencies
which is super neat and is a nice
property of having zeros and ones and so
once we can get the expected value of
y's here we can actually figure out what
the answer to this what the expected
answer to these betas are and that what
that's going to do is it's going to
allow me figure out what the interaction
is or what the relationship is between
the estimated additive effects
their interaction effect okay so there's
a lab there's some map that goes in
there I'm not going to show all that but
too far so you'll see that here for the
multiplicative epistatic model
essentially the additive effects will
end up being zero and and the
interaction is is is nonzero in the
duplicate factor we have the additive
effects being positive or negatively
related to the interaction effect and
similarly in my sub functionalization or
what I'm calling sub functionalisation
and when when B is less than one there
will be a negative relationship between
the additive effects in the interaction
and when D is greater than one there
will be a positive relationship between
the additive effects and the interaction
okay unfortunately if you want to test
all pairs of epistatic Llosa you run
into a put this thing down because I'm
using it too much you run into a
multiple testing problem here in even
with a modest amount of markers you know
like 6000 you have about 17 million
tests okay and one of the things I can
do is we can use some properties of
linear mixed models and epistatic
genetic covariances where if you okay so
this this looks disgusting but but but
the most important thing is you have
some genetic effect okay and then you
can have the epistatic effect that is
simply the Hadamard product of two
separate genetic covariance matrices
okay and with the zero one coating this
all works out very beautifully and it
drops out such that this Hadamard
product is exactly equal to the
covariance that you would calculate
based on all of these pairwise
interactions okay so then you can
estimate a genetic effect for their
interaction and you can estimate a
genetic effect for the additive portion
you can also transform these back into
marker effects but that's really ugly
because you have to make a matrix of
this size so I haven't actually done
that but so I'm utilizing this property
to keep from having a deal with 17
million okay and so then I'm just going
to look at what the
what the relative relationship between
the additive effects is in the
interaction okay so this is the classic
way you think of a phenotype at some
function of the genetics and what I'm
going to do is is I want to find groups
of markers that make sense to test for
epistatic interactions okay and but I
want a relatively small number of those
that way I don't have seventeen million
of them right so what I do is I might
pick say two homie ologist chromosome
arms right chromosome one a from our one
the short arm of chromosome one a and
the short arm of chromosome one B right
and I can pluck those out and so I can
model the rest of the genomic effect
account for it
while I look at the additive effect of
each chromosome arm as well as their
interaction so and then and then I use a
series of nested likelihood ratio tests
to test whether or not these additive
effects are greater than or have a
nonzero variance and then to test
whether or not the interaction has a
nonzero variance and once I establish
that both of those things are true okay
then I can look at the relationship
between their additive effects and their
interaction okay and so I did actually
test this on real data
I have also simulated it but I think the
real data example is much more
interesting and so relatively larger
population
twelve hundred lines seventy five
hundred observations I also have about
six thousand markers that have been
pretty heavily filtered for missing this
and minor allele frequency I impute this
and then I set the heterozygous calls to
the major allele because I need
everything to be zeros and ones right so
I can't have a heterozygous call and so
essentially these small two percent of
heterozygous calls that I get I just set
to the major allele and then importantly
because of this epistatic model I'm
showing you effectively I've made the
assumption that having that being
functional allows you to increase the
value say yield okay so then I have to
fade the markers bye-bye there
effect and so I just run a G wash and
then I just multiply sorry and then I
just have all of the positive effect
alleles be a 1 and the negative effect
alleles be a zero okay
and so yeah here's the result from that
so here I have out of 42 homologous
chromosome arm pairs I test all 42 of
them and I find eight of them that have
significant additive effects as well as
significant interaction and you'll
notice I find I find so here I've
colored these the red indicates that
that there was a negative relationship
between the additive effect and the
interaction the blue indicates a
positive relationship between the
additive effect in the interaction okay
so the blue corresponds like be greater
than one or like that over dominance and
the red corresponds to more of a sub
functionalisation and then these black
ones are are a couple that I found that
have significant interaction effects but
don't necessarily have a significant
correlation to the additive effect so I
don't I don't know what's going on with
those ones but you'll notice that I have
tested these at an alpha of p equal or
you know alpha 0.05 and remember I did
not correct for multiple but this has
not been corrected for multiple testing
and when I do I basically lose these
things which isn't super surprising but
kind of frustrating for me these multi
kernel models get kind of difficult to
fit because I thought okay so I've got
this whole I've got this big genome
right and it's having an effect on yield
and then taking one tiny little piece
out of it and I'm setting it aside and
I'm asking what is the variance that you
explained and then what is the variance
that your interactions explaining and I
think that I'm just getting so small
that it's hard to find really
significant differences but I did but
you know I did do this for actually all
861 chromosome pairs regardless of
whether or not they are homey ologists
or not and I do find signal all over the
genome particularly within the B genome
there's a lot of signal there's also a
lot of signal between the a and the B
but not necessarily on what we believe
our homologous regions so yeah and this
is
this is at a bonferroni of 10 to the -5
roughly so and and the bulk of them tend
to show something that looks like this
sub functionality which I really I guess
I haven't really had enough chance to
digest these results from what why I
would expect this but it is interesting
to see okay so in conclusion epistatic
interactions do if you're important but
I'm finding them mostly within and
across the a and B genomes and not
necessarily how many Oligocene I do keep
one of those homologous interactions but
one out of you know I don't know 20 or
whatever it was is arguably maybe not
the most significant thing in the world
and it may be because the signal is
being drowned by having multiple
interactions it because there's such
large pieces of chromatin I'm testing so
one way I've been thinking about
circumventing this moving forward is now
that we actually have a reference genome
I plan on scanning the genome for
triplicates genes so basically you find
one gene in the a genome one and the B
one and the B and then you take the mark
of its nearest those and then basically
I would just use the multiplicative
products of those markers and so then I
would be drastically reducing the number
of interactions I'm testing and
therefore I may pick up a lot more
signal and with that I just like to
thank my committee the yannick Soros
group and the small grain field crew who
which I could not have all of this data
without okay thank you
[Applause]
yeah but see but then but you're still
making so you're still actually making I
think that's the problem if you you've
already done the test right you already
asked whether or not they're additive is
significant right so then so then you
have to take that into account right so
you have to you have to have a
correction for the fact that you said
okay now that I'm saying that they're
additive is significant then but yeah I
mean you could do that you could just
condition on it and not worry about it I
mean right right all right yeah and
right right did
all right yeah yeah okay sure
there's also a lot more of them but yeah
it could be I mean I could speculate a
lot on this too especially since there's
been there's also been translocations
that have happened since right and so I
have not been specifically careful about
saying okay this this region is exactly
syntetic to that region on these three
genomes I basically made the assumption
that there's more or less gene Sentinel
comas from the chromosome which is I
mean which is arguably a pretty rough
assumption to make I just wanted to do
this genome scan to see if I can even
see it right yeah but yeah it's possible
that it's possible that you could have
ancient duplications doing this I would
expect them to have diverged to the
point of being either completely
additive or fixed by by that point
though I in fact I'm concerned that part
of the reason I don't see this is
actually because wheat is too old of a
hybrid even though it's not that old so
it was the last hybridization that
happened like nine ten thousand years
ago yeah Christine
right so I think I think if you wanted
to ask that question the cool way to do
it would be to do like exome capture and
then and then you could grab all of
those things since the problem is that
my markers aren't in genes necessarily
right but week has like large has really
large regions of chromatin or LD blocks
so I'm hoping that I get that a better
response to your question would be yes
you could you could find all of those
but then how do you decide whether or
not they're different because they're
certainly not identical by descent right
and they might be identical by state in
their amino acid sequence but without
like without sequencing like the
transcriptome you wouldn't even have a
wonderful idea of how yeah how close
they were anyway this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu